how crucial is knowing the personality
type introvert extrovert of your
colleagues in combat business or
choosing an MOS which is an occupation
yeah how crucial is it to know the
personalities of people it's really
crucial knowing and understanding people
is critical in every aspect of life and
that being said the most important part
of knowing people is knowing that you
really can't know people not 100% and I
hear people talk about like personality
types and there's these tests and these
these categories and stuff like that and
honestly I've never been familiar with
that but you know you can put people in
different categories but for me when you
put person in a category by themselves
right that's only 50% of the situation
the other 50% is the other people that
they're working with mmm so I want to
know not just what type of personality
they have because that's a that's a like
I said that's half of the equation the
other half is how do they interact with
other people and other people's
personalities how do they handle
slackers how do they handle
overachievers how do they handle
loudmouths how do they handle submissive
people how do they handle aggressive
people those are all different
personality traits I want to know I want
to see how people are gonna handle other
personalities and then I want to also
know how they're gonna handle certain
situations pressure conflict Authority
responsibilities I mean I want to know
not just what their personalities but
how they're gonna react cuz you can get
people that are a really easy example is
people that are super aggressive but
they fold under pressure and you can get
people that are super passive that fold
under pressure and vice versa you can
get someone that's super quiet and
humble and under pressure they're just
strong
so that's what I want to know I don't
care what kind of personality you have I
mean I do to an extent but I want to
know how it interoperates with the with
the world with the people and with the
situations that you're gonna face and
how do you do that you do that by
observing them while they're dealing
with other people while they're dealing
with pressure situations that's just a
reality yeah and you can't you can have
an idea
you know I won't say that you won't be
able to predict it but you'll get
surprised sometimes you get surprised on
a person that you think is all tough and
they fold or a person that you think is
weak and they're strong so you will get
fooled sometimes a lot of times you're
you know you're probably right
60% of the time 70% of the time yeah
yeah big one is also how how they react
when stuff goes bad
like when stuff doesn't go their way
yeah you know and that's a spectrum too
but and some you can meet someone and or
things are going good you're hiring new
people with growth or whatever whatever
your situation and it's like dang this
guy's I'm so glad I hired this guy but
when something goes wrong they
self-destruct or something like that man
yeah that's I think a critical component
and so I have you know the simple answer
is that there's there's so many
different variables there's so many
different nuances that what you want to
do is you want to know your people yeah
you want to build relationships with
your people so you know them so you
understand them that's what you want to
do you know the r-word relationships
yeah that's what you need that's how you
get to know your people and that's how
you lead them correctly